y han anotó 144 puntos esta temporada de
fútbol anotó todos sus puntos con 50 con
50 goles de campo wow eso es bastante
impresionante 50 goles de campo es como
es el canal récord a una liga nacional
creó el récord es de 60 o algo así
entonces cyan parece ser un individuo
bastante impresionante anotó todos sus
puntos con 50 goles de de campo
entonces me sigue impresionando brian' y
cada uno cada uno vale tres puntos ahora
esto es fútbol americano sólo para
dejarlo en claro cada gol de campo vale
tres puntos él jugó el jugó en 16
partidos esta temporada 16 partidos
cuántos goles de campo anotó y han en
cada juego
asumiendo asumiendo que que en cada
juego realizó los mismos a lo que se
veían es un jugador muy eficiente anotó
todos sus puntos con 50 goles de campo
la misma cantidad en cada juego
así que esa parte consistente y pensemos
en cuántos goles de campo hizo en cada
juego entonces pensemos vamos a
concentrar unos cuantos cuantos goles de
campo hizo en la temporada y en la
temporada en los 244 puntos en total y
vamos a dividir eso entre bueno por cada
gol de campo te dan tres puntos entonces
dividimos entre tres esto nos dará el
número total de goles de campo que tuvo
ian y esto esto es igual esto es igual a
3 le cabe a 144 cuántas veces no lo voy
a hacer de este lado entonces 144
dividido entre 33 no le cabe al 1 pero
le cabe al 14 4 veces 4 por 13 12
restamos nos queda 2 bajamos el 43 de
cada 24 perfectamente ocho veces 8 por 3
24 y no tenemos residuos por lo tanto
144 dividido entre 3 esto es igual a 48
48 así que durante toda la temporada
y 48 goles de campo wow
muy bien muy bien pero pero aún no hemos
respondido a la pregunta dice cuántos
que cuántos hace en cada juego asumiendo
que anota los mismos para cada juego así
eso es el total durante 16 juegos
durante 16 juegos anotó 48 goles de
campo y para encontrar la cantidad de
goles de campo que hace en cada juego
vamos a dividir esto entre 16 así que 48
goles de campo en total dividido entre
16 partidos esto es igual a tres goles
de campo por cada juego tres goles de
campo por cada juego y la pregunta era
cuántos goles de campo hacían en cada
juego la respuesta es exactamente tres
por cada juego